well
[Music]
how are you greetings from cristian cásseres
with his new newscast for today monday
october 11 this morning a man
died and two suspects
fled after a shooting the
las vegas metropolitan police say this
happened near the  At eight o'clock at night at
the Pérez Egert intersection, an Asian man
inside a bus
allegedly started an argument with two
African-American men, the three
of them got out of the car, however, this fight
continued until a shootout
broke out. The authorities are reviewing the
security cameras to try  To
identify and find all
suspects
An escaped inmate is
back behind bars this morning
after a 36-hour search
Saturday Police said Tyler
Nery fled
the County Court rehab center when he returned last night
was  arrested is now in the
night county detention center
facing charges for running away
lario l  línea saúco school for
air traffic control and bad weather for
canceling several trips according to a web
page that provides information on
flights in real time and I say that
southwest canceled more than a thousand flights on
Sunday this is the only airline that
is reported to have  had so many
trip cancellations and we went to
the weather forecast we will have a
windy day today reaching 77
degrees we will continue in those temperatures
for the rest of the week with highs in
the 70s and lows in the 40s i am a christian
what to do about the news
inclusion in Spanish good day
[Music]